i want to be really clear because there
are a lot of people who who sort of
you know get by on on social media drama
and it's there's a throttling and
there's a counter claim look
we've had false copyright claims we've
never lost on those right half asian
lawyer bill richmond
we've filed counter claims we've had to
file petitions of information in the
past
this is very different this is the big
one we filed an official notice
uh uh that we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate motion for um
an injunction in
conjunctive relief because we have two
strikes in our account right now
and we have good reason to believe that
there may be a third
one that they're looking for
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
man on youtube
i think kinda maybe stephen crowder
welcome back yeah no i i depends on when
this is exactly
running uh two-week suspension from
youtube
right from the second hard strike so not
on youtube right now but
you know once upon a time the biggest
right-leaning channel ever in the
history of the platform
okay so let's be clear about what's
going on here this is an emergency
meeting
of the reuben crowder thing
because you could be booted you now have
two strikes on your channel channel i'll
let you go into why you got the strikes
but in essence if you get one more
strike if you even
sniff near susan wajeski
that's it your entire channel your
catalog the entire thing your business
gone yeah yeah the business the the 12
to 15 people that i employ
uh gone and by the way that means within
only a
series of a few months you and all other
right-leaning people as well because
let's be clear here
uh i talked about michael knows with
this i'm basic [ __ ] pumpkin spice
conservatism i mean you know it's not
like anything that i really believe is
all that radical and i've been here
think of you as basic [ __ ] yeah i i
really am and it's okay it's a moniker
that i wear proudly nothing about me is
very radical i'm pro second amendment
i'm pro first amendment i'm pro-ending
the drug war
i believe in uh things like heartbeat
bills with abortion it's pretty much
conservative christian who advocated
that people not have sex until they're
married i know
crazy keep me away from the kids but i
want to be really clear because there
are a lot of people who
who sort of you know get by on on social
media drama and it's there's a
throttling and there's a counter claim
look
we've had false copyright claims we've
never lost on those right i'm half asian
lawyer bill richmond
we've filed counter claims we've had to
file petitions of information in the
past
this is very different this is the big
one we filed an official notice
uh uh that we are filing a lawsuit with
youtube and an immediate motion for
an injunction injunctive relief because
we have two strikes in our account right
now
uh and we have good reason to believe
that there may be a third
one that they're looking for how do i
know this because
they're just waiting right and because
it's not very clear
i should say it is very clear that we
didn't violate specific policies
uh and so they said well maybe the
totality of in tandem so if people want
to know and by the way
people can still watch us uh we're
available at mug club you know in blaze
lottery credit.com club and
we always recommend that people join
anyways because there's an hour worth of
extra content every day
but we're still making sure that the
free content is available on apple on
android spotify
and right now on rumble though we can't
stream live it's a little glitchy we're
working with them
but um you know the issue here with
youtube to give an idea on a couple of
strikes
the first one that came in was a warning
that was supposed to be a heart strike
uh on uh voter fraud now i have never
said that uh
donald trump won the election that the
ghost of hugo chavez
you know ring rigged smartmatic uh and
and
whisked away wisconsin uh but just like
amy klobuchar just like elizabeth warren
just like jimmy carter
i said that individual voter fraud does
occur and of course
as they said it occurs far more with
mass mail in voting
just because there are fewer checks and
balances there are fewer ways to sort of
verify
and so the segment that we did was
almost comical in us saying
you know not that there's anything wrong
with that thing not that there's any
vote fraud but we cross-reference voter
roles
with addresses that didn't exist on
google earth sent interns with a copy of
that day's paper
at an empty lot on camera live to say
look
we know that it occurs i think it might
have been 30 or 40 addresses
they said that's a violation of the
election fraud policy
okay the second one was wait wait can i
pause you there because i think just
sort of philosophically
and i don't want to get myself booted
now too but right
we're not even addressing the
philosophic issue which is should you be
allowed to just say what you want to say
in a free country
right you know a supposedly open
platform and everything else i mean it's
just worth mentioning that that
you're you're saying you didn't break
the rules but the the question really is
are the rules just completely insane
no absolutely and by the way we were
never told that we were wrong too to be
clear no one is no one has
proven a matter of fact we got fact
checked and some people said that we
were wrong when really
the fact check ended up being they
changed the voter rolls the the next
night to a new address that didn't exist
that was one that was part of a series
so
i don't want to get too off into the
weeds there but these were things where
we did our due diligence to a comical
degree
that was the point of this segment the
first actual strike i believe i don't
remember the exact sequence was
coveted 15 uh 15 days to flatten the
curve a one year anniversary
now what did we do we showed them cdc
saying don't wear masks say wear masks
don't wear double masks wear double
masks we won't have a vaccine in a year
i wouldn't take the vaccine if it was
done in a year take the vaccine all of
this stuff right
which is really tough to navigate as an
american from what i understand the
statement that was a violation
was something to be effective because i
don't want you to get booted something
to the effect
of the covet is significantly more
lethal to old people
we know that we need to figure out how
to protect the most vulnerable but for
some reason due to the immune response
according to the cdc and we always list
our references available on our website
young people uh are significantly less
at risk of death from kova than the flu
for some reason young but old people
it's way more deadly
we use the cdc mortality tables we've
been given a specific reason as to what
the violation is but the time
code that i believe were given was where
that statement was made and people can
we're the only show i know of
if you go to lydewithcrowder.com every
single episode has a page
with the references the references for
that statement were the cdc and world
health organization
now some people can say well you're
making it seem like it's not as big of
it
people may not take it seriously well a
that's not what i'm saying and b
if we're going to follow the science
it's important to understand how
different immune systems respond to a
novel
virus it's important that you don't tell
people shut up if they have a problem
with a two-year-old wearing a mask
if you say well hold on a second we
don't have two or four-year-olds wear a
mask for the flu
where there are significantly more
deaths for younger people it is
significantly deadlier for older
people or the immuno compromise you're
not allowed to discuss that the most
recent one this is the second strike
here
this is why there's a lawsuit which i
really didn't want this to have to come
to i would just want to do the show
is when i was recently celebrating
actually praising the officer who saved
that young girl's life who was about to
be stabbed by mackay bryant
i said not only is that justified from
the police
i believe it's necessary because if the
police cannot shoot someone who is in
the process of attempting to stab
you then we might as well not have
police and i believe that we should have
police
that was considered bullying and
harassment but not technically
but the totality may be over time
indicative of bullying harassing by
supporting the police
who is that bullying who are you
bullying by saying that
you supported the cops saving a woman's
life who was about to be decapitated
who was that bullying apparently it
might be considered reveling in in the
death of
mackay bryant i don't know we don't have
an official answer yeah and we can't get
these official answers from people at
youtube
but let me just be really clear with
people out there this is tantamount to
saying to everyone out there if you're
conservative we don't want you look if
they are saying
hey look you cannot discuss the
mortality rates of cobalt you cannot
point out that the cdc has been
inconsistent and confusing which has
made it harder for americans to stay
safe
you are not allowed to say that voter
fraud has ever occurred
to any degree and you are not allowed to
support police
if they save someone's life mid-stabbing
if the person committing the stabbing
happens to be
a girl of color that is saying you are
not welcome on this platform
if you hold these views now if they say
that that's fine the issue there is i'm
pro-business
i'm anti-fraud youtube says all views
are welcome
those strikes without description tell
us otherwise
we need to know the rule book because
people's livelihoods
depend on it well crowder you know last
week i put up an interview
with david horowitz i'm sure you know
david horowitz and i've
never in in all of my years of doing
this show i've never edited for content
except one time
i had a guest come on who was drunk and
stoned and we ended up editing
just to basically save this person's
career it's the only time we've edited
for
i did that once too we can compare notes
off there this person was doing crack
in the laundry room no joke yeah he was
probably the same person
but uh but last week for the first time
we edited for content because david
horowitz a free man in what i thought
was a free country
dared to say two sentences that i knew
my channel could be deleted
like that so we had to we censored it on
youtube i mean simple as that i put it
up in my locals community
but now i'm having you you crazy right
wing maniac well you're such a tease i
know i want to hear the two sentences
and that's the issue right what's going
to happen is of course all people want
to hear the sentences
and they assume that it's like not
seeing the monster in a scary movie you
assume that it's worse than it is
that's how you radicalize people when
you see these new york times articles
saying
hey radicalization it has a picture with
me next to philip defranco
and then by the way hey i was in there
come on were you in there too
that's right yeah i just you know again
i would never imagine that you would be
in there
radicalizing people dave reuben
incredible
man but what happens is then they
complain about echo chambers right well
look
what's more radical a view of someone
who believes what the guy who believes
in a flat tax or the people who believe
in 90 income tax the guy who believes
that police need to be demilitarized to
a degree but that they also need to be
able to do their job and they should
wear body cams or the people who believe
we should have no police whatsoever we
should have no prisons whatsoever
like rashida tlape like aoc like these
people believe this is not a radical
point of view
this the reason for this lawsuit is look
you know could i uh uh at some point
sail off under the sunset with support
from people at mud club
i don't know further but at some point i
could but what about the next kid
who wants to start a business you know i
started this in 2009 maybe 2008 with a
blue bed sheet behind me
i don't see a world in which their point
of view is even allowed to be expressed
and we talk about othering people
youtube is othering an entire half of
the country and by the way
more than 80 of black people while we're
talking about
the mackay bryant and that officer
situation more than 80 black people want
at least as much of a police presence as
exists now
if not more and because that isn't a
view that is permissible on
we silence these minorities too we host
people under look
if the guy who did change my mind which
was
antithetical to the you know sort of
24-hour news
cycle if it bleeds it leads if that's
removed as impermissible
no conservative viewpoint is permissible
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell